لانا طول الموسم السابع تطارد كلوب في
ليفربول شاكيرا تستفزه والدتك
ومن هم اسماك القرش في حرب كره القدم هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه
امام برشلونه في نهائي كاس السوبر
الاسباني النادي الملكي نشر اليوم عبر
حسابه الرسمي صور حضور الفريز لحفل
استقبال داخل مقر السفاره الاسبانيه في
السعوديه برفقه رئيسي برشلونه
تفاعل رواد السوشل ميديا مع الحلقه الاولى
من سلسله الوثائقي حرب كره القدم وتحديدا
حول عباره اسماك القرش التي يبدو انها
تحولت لوسيله هجوميه من جانب خصوم ريال
مدريد الاسباني الهجوم جاء هذه المره عبر
التصريحات ادلى بها جبر رئيس الاتحاد
الاوروبي حيث اوضح بان هنالك الكثير من
القروش التي تسبح في بحر عالمي كره القدم
وانه بحسب جبرا منذ لحظه سماعه عن دور
السوبر لاول مره ادركه ان من وراء الامر
من يظن انه نادي النخبه في اشاره منه الى
ريال مدريد الاسباني
ننتقل الان الى انجلترا حيث اطلقت
اجماهيره ليفربول هاشتاج كلوب هذا
الهاشتاغ يطالبوا برحيل يورجن كلوب بعد
سقوط امام برايتن بثلاثيه في الدوري
المحلي ويواجهك الامر عقده تاريخيه في
موسمه السابع مع الفرق التي تولى قيادتها
بدء من مايز وبروسيا دورتموند مرورا
بليفربول حيث لم يحقق معها كلوب اي نتائج
ايجابيه وتلقى الريدز امس خسارته السادسه
خلال الموسم الحالي في البريميرليج تراجع
على اثرها الى المركز التاسع
الختام مع المغنيه شاكيرا واغنيتها
الجديده المثيره للجدل اوت اوف يورليك
التي تخطت على اليوتيوب عتابات السبعين
مليون مشاهده حتى الان الحديث هنا ليس حول
الكلمات المثيره للجدل وانما حول والده
نجم كره القدم الدوليه المعتزل التي
استفزتها شاكيرا بوضع تمثال ساحره سوداء
مثبته على شرفتي منزلها في برشلونه وبحسب
التقرير الصحفيه
طلبت من احد المقربين من شاكيرا اداره وجه
الساحره كي لا يكون في مقابل منزل العائله
مباشره باعتبار ان الطرفين يسكن يعني في
الشارع الا ان المغنيه تجاهلت الامر تماما
بل وقامت بتصويره في الاغنيه الجديده